lisp a dynamic general purpose
programming language famous for
pioneering many of the programming
techniques we take for granted today it
was created in 1958 by John McCarthy at
MIT making it the second high-level
language ever after Fortran the year
before however it was the first
interpreted language that could be
executed step by step without a compiler
in addition it's responsible for a
variety of other language Innovations
like recursion Dynamic typing garbage
collection first class functions and
more its name stands for list processor
and syntactically it's known for its
prolific use of parentheses because at
its core almost everything is treated as
a linked list data structure each
element in the list is called a cons or
Constructor which contains two pointers
the car points to the actual data while
the CDR points to the next element in
the list developers write s Expressions
which might start with a function or
operator followed by one or more
arguments this gives rise to a powerful
macros feature where developers can
extend the syntax of lists and create
domain-specific languages it's like a
programmable program language common
lisp is still in use today but it's
directly inspired many other languages
like scheme closure Ruby and JavaScript
just to name a few to get started
install common lisp on your machine then
create a file ending in dot LSP first
create an S expression which can
represent an atom like a number or
symbol or a list of multiple values to
print to the standard output we can
reference the format function followed
by T for true then the string we want to
print out and it contains a ton of
built-in functions like print to
simplify things Define a local variable
with a let keyword and it will be
lexically scoped to the context in which
it's defined however you can also define
global variables with death parameter or
death VAR which are dynamically scoped
and can be used anywhere all these
variables can be modified however you
can also create immutable data with def
constant lisp is multi-paradigm but most
well known as a functional language use
the dev on keyword which is definitely
the way you pronounce it to define a
function it can take one or more
parameters and is optionally followed by
a string to Define its purpose we can
use the star operator to apply Pi by the
input radius and the last expression in
the function body will automatically be
used as the return value it was the
first language to support higher order
functions where we might do something
like create a list then use another
function called mapcar to Loop over that
list and call the function we just
defined on every single element inside
of it it also includes a built-in macro
called Loop for general purpose
iteration what it doesn't have though is
a while loop not a problem though if you
want to create one just write your own
macro to extend the language now run
your code with the clip interpreter this
has been lisp in 100 seconds hit the
like button if you want to see more
short videos like this thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one
[Music]